good so uh now in the second part of the
lecture uh my plan is to work out uh
some uh to through some classes of
queries that that meet various degrees
of optimality
for update and enumeration delay and
then we also see some trade-offs
but I have it turns out more slides so
I'm happy to after the end of the
lecture to discuss other aspects if you
guys are interested
um so uh the question now we ask is can
we get constant update time and constant
enumeration delay
and uh uh and this is actually a very
reasonable question and we want this in
in worst case so it turns out there is a
class of queries which you you know
throughout uh you know database Theory
over the past decade uh uh was was a
rage that is you know it has been used
the discuss of queries to show nice
result in a very num a large number of
settings parallel query evaluation even
provenance management uh probabilistic
databases uh uh finite course or model
uh for for streaming processing and now
also for IVM and this is a class of
so-called hierarchical queries and I
will explain what this means and in
particular we see there is a queue in
front uh which has something to do with
the with which variables are free in the
query and I will explain these these
terms in a sec and this was actually
discussed first in in a paper by by
nicorice Weichert and Christopher halls
and uh yes Kepler
um but then we can go go beyond uh it
turns out that using some prior works we
had and the uh this idea now is also
implemented the relation AI we can also
uh have queries that become Q
hierarchical under functional
dependencies
right so in general they are not you
know in the in the good class but if we
know there are functional dependencies
holding the database they suddenly you
can actually uh provide efficient
maintenance for them and then uh
recently we also looked at queries with
free access patterns so where the
variables three variables uh the
variables in the head are decomposed
into input and output variables that is
if you are given values for the input
variables you want to enumerate over the
uh the the pupils over the output
variables and this
you know some of them actually can also
get this very nice complexity and more
recently
we look at queries that are not
hierarchical but become few hierarchical
under your writings that use Q
hierarchical queries assuming that that
we want anyway to enumerate all the all
the answers to all the queries and then
we fix a particular order of the
enumeration
good so let me tell you about the
hierarchical queries what they are so a
query is hierarchical if you look in the
query for any two variables there are
sets of atoms in the query either are
either disjoint or one is containing the
other
and and this was actually introduced
first by by Dan uh in a paper on
probabilistic databases because it
turned out that hierarchical queries
work the queries out of the conjunctive
queries without self joins that can be
computed exactly for which we can
compute exactly from the probability in
a probabilistic database
and I will show you here an example and
why also I try to give the information
why they are called hierarchical so take
for instance this query so we have this
four factors and these are consider them
relay uh variables uh and what you can
see is that a here appears everywhere so
we can say that a dominates all other
variables so whenever you know if you
look at the set of atoms of a it
includes the set of atoms of any other
variable so we can place a at the top
yeah and then we look at other variables
let's say look at b b uh basically
appears here and there
and the B is dominated by a but
dominates D so we can put B and then we
can put D now B
if you look at its atoms this set of
atoms is disjoint from the set of atoms
of let's say c e and f which are
somewhere else so they are on a
different branch right and C dominates E
and F so we put C on top of E and F and
E and F are these joints so we put them
separately so we can build such a
hierarchy
yeah and what is also interesting about
the hierarchy if you look at the uh this
uh uh uh you know essentially this is a
hypercraft representation of the query
uh you get the hyper range that goes
actually you know over
uh over all the all the variables along
along the branch
right and then this Branch ends with R
this Branch here ends with s this Branch
ends with t and this Branch ends with u
so there is always such a you know all
the variables along the branch they are
all covered by at least one relation one
factor
one hyper Ridge right so this is for
instance the the simplest
non-hierarchical query
right so you see we have r s and t uh a
appears in both r and s b appears in uh
both s and t
but a does not dominate b and a is not
disjoint from B
yeah because they actually have in
common s but each of them also has in
common has another
you know uh hyper rage R and T
respectively so this query is actually
considered hard
okay
good so what is Q then in the Q
hierarchical well a query skill
hierarchical if it is hierarchical and
the three variables dominate the bound
variables
excuse me yourselves joint right
in this well yes here I assume this that
if you don't have searches but even if
you have cell joints the definition will
still hold you just assume we talk about
atoms so the atoms will be distance even
though they talk about the same relation
you consider the atoms to be distinct
yeah so a query is too high but but you
are right that the the so if I go back
and I'll make a complete statement about
you know which queries are actually
really uh tractable in that sense of
constant update time and constant delay
we'll talk about queries without
self-jones you're right about that
good so what is Q here to go back it
says that the three variables dominate
the bond variable so if you put it in
such a structure you want the three
variables to be at the top
right so there should be no bound
variables mingling with the three
variables right like for instance B here
being bound and B being free you don't
want that yeah
okay so this would be a few hierarchical
query because you need a B and C are all
the ones from the from the head are all
above the others
um now this is hierarchical but not you
hierarchical this is perhaps the
simplest we know of being hierarchical
and not too hierarchical because you see
here B dominates a because B appears in
both uh factors but a only appears in in
s but a is the free one
so a is free but it would be for
instance a q hierarchical if B which
dominated should would also be free
but because if you stop then it is a not
too hierarchy yes so
the thing is for you or everything is
you hierarchical if everything is free
or everything is bound yeah it was a
special case
not however for for the uh for those of
you knowing the notion of frequent X
that fit connects is different from Q
here right so uh uh the Q property is
actually a stricter property than being
fit connects
in particular this particular query is
actually free connects
right but it is not a hierarchy
uh okay so the dichotomy stated the uh
uh in 2017 by the code is this so let Q
be any conjunctive queries without a
query without self-joints and DBA
database if Q is Q hierarchical then the
query answer that needs of one single
Tuple updates and enumeration delay if
you is not your hierarchical then there
is no algorithm with the uh with this
update time and enumeration DeLay So the
size of the database to the power of one
over two minus gamma for any gamma
strictly positive
yeah unless the omv conjecture fails the
one I mentioned before
okay
so I will show you an example now but uh
uh I will show you an example where I
also use functional dependencies so the
idea there is this that we take a query
we look at the functional dependencies
given in the query and then we can you
know rewrite the query it's like we
Chase it right under the functional
dependencies and then what effectively
means is that we look at the at the
schema of every single relation any
compute its closure under the functional
dependencies we are given so we enhance
possibly the schema of every single
relation
and and then we check whether that query
is too hierarchical
and if it is this means that the
original query we started with admits
this very nice property that can be done
with a constant update time and
enumeration DeLay So to give you an
example you know if Sigma is our set of
function dependencies would be this x
implies Y and Y implies that then the
closure of X assuming that we have a
relation with this schema X would now
become x y z
yeah why because X implies Y and Y
implies it so the closure gives us all
of three uh in the same in the same set
so now if the sigmari duct that is the
rewriting under the functional
dependencies of the original query is
still hierarchical then Q admits
constant update time and generation
delay
s the set of variables
so that there are more variables
yeah so so let me so let me show you uh
I'll show you an example I'll share an
example on the next slide so how to
maintain the few hierarchical queries so
um so the way uh Nicole did it is this
so she constructed a factorized
representation of the query answer
uh based based on some prior work we did
on factorized databases so then we know
that this factorization so that need
constant delay enumeration so there
wouldn't be a problem with the with the
delay but then she shows how to apply
updates directly on the factorization
right and then these updates will
actually cause the constant time we
implemented something like that in our
system and where we represent the
factorization of the trio views which I
will exemplify and then we will
materialize the views to speed up
updates and the enumeration so let me
show you this query which is a query I
got from from the relation AI folks so
but of course I change the the actual
names of the variables and relations so
we have essentially a path w x x y y z
and now assume we have a functional
dependency X implies Y and Y implies
that
yeah so uh this query is not
hierarchical this path right because for
instance y uh appears in s and t and X
appears in RNs so they are not disjoint
nor one included in the other the sets
but under functional depends on the
function dependencies we get this that
whenever we have X we can also put y now
right so X was here we can also put Y is
here we can also put that see now you're
attending the identity of it yeah you
change reality yeah so you look at this
query which is a virtual query
essentially and here y implies it so we
add that wherever wise and if we check
now this query it will be actually
hierarchical because that appears every
other dominates everything y the same
and then we then if we take Y and set
apart then X remains on one branch and W
well X dominates sorry uh W and then
after that we have W below
so it is actually a hierarchical so how
this is how we do it we take this
virtual query and we construct a
variable order
basically on order on the variables we
had in the query where we construct it
top down as follows we first look at
which variables dominate other variables
so z and y dominate the all other
variables so we put them at the top in
some order let's say Z1 because they
both you know are the same level of
dominance then below we have X which
dominates W and after that we have w
so we are going to use this variable
order now to maintain and also compute
also Q the original query
so we do it like this so this is the
variable order that I showed you now I'm
going to construct a view tree
that actually with the would represent
my maintenance strategy so what do I do
I put the leaves the relations rsnt
then I will basically have a
materialized views that will join the
relations like I will join S and R and
I'll join it here but what I do also is
that because W is not needed further I
first materialize it away I sorry
aggregate it the way just you know do
variable elimination here why is that
because imagine hypothetically I come
with an update coming from s here yeah
so I fix X I want to be able to just do
a quick look up into this view to figure
out whether that X I have in the update
is also in The View
so I don't want them to carry with me
all the W's because there may be very
many and that will explode the time I
need for update so therefore I try to be
as compact as I can so I only then
propagate here the x's and y's that
agree obviously on the excess and y's
ahead in s but also the X's I have in R
which are also then here
similarly here I don't need any more X
so I remove it I aggregate it away and
then in the join of T and and this view
I uh I I just uh constructed this view
so if I would get an update from here I
can easily look up and and check whether
the Y is in there and I propagate it
like this yeah so I construct these
views which are have the definitions
here but I already explained how we do
it so this is basically a maintenance
strategy that I can always construct it
from such a variable order and the
variable order I can trigly construct it
from the query assuming the query is a
hierarchical query because it will
expose to me that particular hierarchy
of the of the variables
okay so now the question is let's do
some updates so first of all I will
update t
so I have an update a single Tuple
update y 0 uh zero as I said I do the
lookup in here
so this is a constant time operation
uh and I my propagate
uh the this update here it may be that
perhaps I don't find the Y 0 there so
then I stop but in case I find it I will
create a Delta for this other view here
and then I go up and I create a Delta
for The View on top which is basically
aggregating the way y0 from here but y
zero being a single value this summation
goes away remains just this yeah so
effectively the payload whatever z0
points to here will be the whatever
z0y0.2 in uh in the original update and
then at the end again I do the same I
aggregate away is it zero and I get this
and what I do with this Deltas of course
I apply them to the to their view to the
respective View
so I can actually update the state of
the whole database and now each view
update takes all of one time right
because it was just a lookup to just
fetch the the payload now of course
there is a caveat here if we have rings
that have uh you know uh you know
non-constant size elements
then of course it will be proportional
in the size of those elements but for
the time being if we just use
multiplicities then that's that that's
not a problem now let's see something
more interesting we do the update to S
if we do the update to s0y0 now we'll
look up whether we have an x0 in this
View yeah that's fine
so that is something uh not
non-controversial we go up we go to y0
and now we want to propagate further and
we take this y 0 and we have to do a
lookup into relation p
now potentially for y 0 we may have very
many sets except that we have the
functional dependency that y implies
that so then for y 0 we cannot have more
than one zero
yeah so this is how we use the
functional dependencies to maintain the
the the constant time update to our
reviews so this is what happens here to
compute this one here it's basically the
join of this with this but because we
have the functional dependency then this
Z will become a particular
uh uh values at zero right or perhaps
you don't have a match we don't have a y
zero in here in which case we stop
nevertheless in both cases it will cost
us a constant time
so then we propagate further up and uh
it's again the same story we get
constant time update and now
um the the last one is we do update to R
we propagate it up and now we have the
same situation but now for for X for x0
we have to do a lookup in s
again we may take very many y's except
that we have the function dependency X
implies y so then we'll get a single one
so it is again constant time and then we
go up here we can again the same
situation we've seen before width-wise
we have the functional dependencies so
we can use this up so overall we still
have a constant time
yeah so that is important it turns out
that actually from relation AI workload
a lot of queries are actually not to
hierarchical but under functional
dependencies many of them become Q
hierarchical
so this actually uh saves the to some
extent the day now how can we enumerate
right
the results with the with constant delay
so we do a top-down enumeration
what actually perhaps you notice is that
in our bottoma propagation of the
updates we made sure that for instance
this view has pair 6y which are
calibrated with respect to both the
relations RNs because we only uh you
know uh uh let's say a propagate X and
y's here which actually do join so
therefore also the Y Z's here are those
that actually are also here and also the
Y's here so in a sense this
this uh view tray if you look at the top
down is calibrated which makes also the
lookups actually uh uh of constant time
that is if you if you look up from this
one into the relation T you know for
sure you'll find some matches there
so you don't have to you know in order
to find the next Tuple to up to to
enumerate you don't have to indefinitely
go and check for many pairs of y z
whether there is any of them in t no you
know for sure that those that are here
will have at least one matching tip and
similarly uh the ones you have here we
have at least one match in this view
right and the X we have here will have
at least one matching here
but another important aspect of this
Innovation is that you see we factor out
you know the representation so that the
W stay with the X in the original
relation and are not propagated all the
way up because otherwise if we do that
there may be very many W's for x and
then the update time will cost a lot but
keeping it down here means that the
updates will remain very very fast and
the enumeration time is for every X we
go and then we enumerate over the Y's
and the enumeration delay will remain
constant for enumerating all the Y's for
a given X of course we need the
convenient data structure to support
that indices in particular you know
given a z if you want to enumerate over
all the Y's we need the view that says
that that looks like this right given a
z i can enumerate the Y's so we need the
we need the the ordering differently
than the way you've seen it here
similarly here given a y you want to
write the X's you need another view
another you know index structure to do
that enumeration
and basically we enumerate from this
join but I already explained how we
enumerate we check at the very top
whether this is empty if it's empty we
stop there is that there is nothing to
be uh uh to be done otherwise we start
enumerating the zets from here
for each set we then look up in here and
then get the Y's for each y we then do a
lookup in here to get the excess
yeah and for each X we do a lookup in
here to get the W and then we we
continue with the W's and then we
continue with x's so we we basically uh
back backtrack afterwards but every time
we have to do
to basically look up for a tuple it will
be there
yeah yes
videos
[Music]
so the question is what happens if you
have update to R and then update to S
how do you deal with this well you some
order you do Delta R you propagate it
you have data views
right and then you do Delta is
by updating the views between two Deltas
you make sure you don't have to consider
all the possible cases of combining the
new Delta with the old version of a
relation you know and or the X Delta is
on because you know if you look at all
these cases there may be exponentially
many in the number of relations
so you want to basically keep that uh
compact construct time so if your
upgrade size are you considering it as a
constant say the number of people that
are being updated so so this is
I think it would basically the time will
be proportional to the size of the batch
of object you do
voice it seems to also work when you
have this takeaway constraints yes
yes it can also work but then the time
the update time will be dependent on
that degree
yeah exactly
like this query of a database that
doesn't satisfy the functional
dependencies uh if it doesn't satisfy
the functional dependency then this
query will be in another class will not
be too hierarchical uh considered right
so then I think
um
so the query is only hierarchical you
know equivalent to hierarchical query
under on the database to satisfy
functions but the query itself if you
look at it once you apply the functional
dependencies is hierarchical and you can
evaluate it in good sometimes over any
will it give you a number approximation
sometimes
uh what happens is that if you evaluate
the query then that is this plan you
know use this particular plan what you
would get is of course you get the exact
answer but the time will suffer in
particular the updates from here to here
may cost you linear time okay so overall
the update time will be winner
remain constant
right
we suppose I have a query that can
functional dependencies the query is not
hierarchical but somehow uh it turns out
to be equivalent to hierarchical one
method guaranteed is are you gonna get
it by the Computing the closure and
doing the substitution right I think so
yes so it's completely but I think so
yes I mean you know in our paper is
actually a assistance paper we didn't
look at that that completion but uh but
I yeah so that that's why my conjectures
we can actually talk a bit more about
that it can be shown
it's very nice yes
okay for the questions no okay so let me
go ahead so what are the open questions
here uh can we achieve worst case
optimality for single people update
beyond the two hierarchical queries so
this is a a question uh worst case
optimal here will not necessarily mean
constant update time and constant delay
but some other times in delay and I will
show you a class that actually can get
that
um and as I mentioned already before in
practice average constant time might be
enough
um even if we don't obtain this sort of
worst case optimalities uh and the
question is which queries admit average
constant type or single Tuple updates
and uh
you know in discussions with the with
Mahmoud we realized that actually that
there is some old work by whom called
the query decomposition Lemma which can
be used to effectively transform uh uh a
genetic joint algorithm or lethal Trigon
algorithm into a maintenance algorithm
at least under inserts it is still open
whether we can do this under under
deletes so that's that ongoing work
and um and the question also is what is
the complexity trade-off between update
time and immersion delay if we draw for
instance the Q property right or the
hierarchical property
okay so I will mention uh some of the
the results in this space
uh there are some references and now
let's go beyond queue if you heard of Q
from Star Trek right potentially you
cannot go beyond it you know you have to
they they let it you know you freeze
that that's the best you can do so I
will take this simple hierarchical query
without the tube property yeah this one
and see what's happening for this query
um it turns out this that um first of
all we get this lower bound this was
actually the original lower bound shown
in a in a paper by uh by by Nicole
namely that for this query there is no
algorithm that needs arbitrary
processing time this update times square
root of n minus you know n to 1 over 2
minus gamma enumeration delay n2r over 2
minus gamma for any gamma strictly
greater than zero unless the OMD
conjecture fails yeah so there is this
this cuboid here this is a no-go cuboid
assuming we agree with the conjecture
yeah
so now how can we do it one approach is
the eager update approach that is we get
the update
we actually uh maintain the materialized
results so we push the update all the
way to the end
and the enumeration then will be trivial
because you know you already have the
result so you can just enumerate from it
so that gives us basically on this uh in
this 3D uh uh coordinates gives us a
linear update time because we have for
instance if we update to s
for a b we may get linearly many A's
right so the update time will be linear
in that case if we update to R it will
be constant because you know A and B
will be fixed you just check into s and
then you update this one right so uh but
um uh the the delay the delay will be
constant yeah so it is on on this uh on
this plane
this is eager now you have lazy right
which says which is the kind of you know
standard approach right like you're just
insert in the database and you don't
care you defer the propagation of the
update right and and that means that
effectively uh we only update to the
base relations and that will be constant
time but the enumeration will have to
pay the price
right but the hope is that in the
meantime you get so many inserts deletes
that overall is still better than
actually having to uh eagerly propagate
the update over every time what we get
here so basically you know for the for
the delay it will be cons it will be a
linear because you have to evaluate the
query essentially over the new database
that was updated so how can we do that
we just first eliminate the dangling
tuples right so that is we just filter
out R using S and then we just enumerate
from r
so that will be a linear time
the question is is there any algorithm
that admits something in between right
these two extrins in particular anything
in between might mean sublinger update
time and sublinger enumeration delay and
the answer is yes we can achieve
anything on this line
right
um
and in particular this line touches the
cube weight on this Edge and this is
where we become actually weak part
optimal yeah so this edge here this
point here has the coordinates you know
you take linear uh pre-processing square
root of n update time and square root of
n delay
yeah and um and why is weak part
optimality optimal because you know um
you may be able perhaps you know the it
is not precluded by by this gray cuboid
here to to descend on one of the
directions right so you might be able
while keeping one of the dimensions the
same to to descend on the other
dimension or to go on this other
dimension here so this is why it's just
weak it's not strong
okay so how can we do that yeah again I
will not to go again and tell you uh um
um how to uh how to partition we are we
assume we know already we partition
light and heavy we now have only two
because we have uh we I want to
partition on B in R right so I get
basically two queries only the light and
the heavy and I will actually going to
show you this because now we have a
different type of query a query that has
some output which is non-scalar right
you have to enumerate something and that
will allow me to introduce another
technique which is used in IVM uh quite
commonly how to do efficient enumeration
uh over over a union offsets
uh okay so the light case is very easy
we just materialize the results so we
have R here and S here we just
materialize the result and the and the
materialization uh uh you know in the
pre-processing step can be done in inert
time and after that uh if you want to
enumerate to just enumerate from this
result one two after the other and that
will give you constant delay and in case
of update what do you do you update here
let's say uh this relation
um and then uh you know that b0 is light
you just look it up on the other side
and then you propagate the updates yeah
and that will cost you of course of one
uh on the other side if you have a b0
update here you have to look up in here
but b0 may be paired with at most N2
Epsilon Ace so that actually gives you
uh also uh an update of end to Epsilon
on that side
okay in the heavy case this is an
interesting case so what do you do with
this so we have this heavy on B so what
they do is materialize the heavy the
heavy values and we maintain the heavy
values this is what we are going to do
so this is the The View tree we use
right so the the button here we have the
the the the relation which is heavy we
know that the the B's here
you know all the bees are heavy and we
have at most n21 minus 13 none of them
if we aggregate away a we only keep the
the heavy B's we know that there are
again n to one minus Epsilon of them and
you see in the pre-processing if we are
going to intersect this list of B's with
the ones in s we get at most ng1 minus
Epsilon B's in the view of the top which
is the intersection and now the
challenge is to maintain this but this
can be maintained very very simply
all right can be maintained uh
hold on
can be maintained simply but you know
first of all before maintaining I will
show you how you can enumerate
so
we know that you know the top view here
has n21 minus Epsilon B's right
right now every B if you look in the
relation below
have its own Ace
now the thing is this you cannot just
say uh I want to enumerate the A's at
the End by just enumerating the A's of
the first B then in writing the A's of
the second B and the third B and so on
why because there may be the case that
different A's or the same a is fairly
different B's in that case you the
numerate an a several times
but that's not what we want with the
delay the delay should be for the case
where we enumerate every distinct a
yeah so how can we possibly enumerate
from n minus x n to 1 minus Epsilon
buckets of a values right
right so that you know the a there may
be different A's that they may be the
same A's in the different buckets but at
the end the animation procedure should
give me all the distinct A's only so
what would be the delay in that case
yeah
so the delay in that case can be
actually obtained as n to 1 minus six
you know that is the number of buckets
we have assuming that within each bucket
that is for every B we can enumerate its
A's with constant delay which is the
case because the B's and A's are paired
in the same relation r
yeah and this is actually going back to
Durant and the in a paper in CSL 2011
it's actually a cute algorithm I thought
you might be interested in case you
don't know it so the idea is this
imagine we enumerate we actually
numerate the distant Tupac in Union of
two sets and both sets allow lookup time
L and irrational delay D yeah then the
union of the sets can be animated with
all of L plus d delay
so imagine the example we have to set S1
and S2 remember with every single step
we make you know we want to output
something uh in you know a particular
value we we cannot just say oh a value
appears already so let me skip it go to
the next one because you don't know how
many you have to skip you may have to
skip very many of them and that will
essentially jeopardize our constant time
delay
so
what do we do first we actually position
ourselves at the beginning of the lists
we assume that each list of force can be
traversed with constant DeLay So we are
here and let's say we the first thing we
do is we check whether A3 is in the
other list so we also assume that the
lookup time in this case can be done
efficiently in this case is uh is is L
right but L and B will be one in our in
most cases right so we look up here
we realize it is not there so what do we
do we output it and then we increment
the pointer in the first list now we
have A4 aha A4 appears in the other list
so the initial you know you know
reaction would be oh I skip over it but
we don't want to do that we have at this
time when we realize that A4 is not in
the other list we have to do something
we have to output something so what do
we do instead we output from the second
list
so the output A5 and we increment both
pointers
okay
so then we check whether A1 is in the
other list it is not we output it and we
increment the pointer in the first list
and then we check A2 it is in the other
list we don't output it
but we output whatever was under the
pointer in the in the second list so we
all put A6
yeah
we reach end of file here so we then
enumerate the rest from the second list
so enumerate A2 A4 and that's it we are
done yeah so the idea is that we'll
always enumerate S2 yeah and we only
enumerate from S1 those that are
actually not in S2 this is the idea
occurs in the other list
so the the head of S1 yes it can be in
which case you don't output it from the
first list you output it from the second
list and we advance the pointer in both
lists but again the element in the
second base appear in the first place
yeah but we never check from the second
list to the first list we must check
from the first is to the second list
thanks
so we can generalize these two uh Union
event sets in which case we get to this
complexity of factor of n which depends
on the number of of lists and this is
actually our big end to one minus
Epsilon right in our example and then L
and D would be one in our case
so effectively this is how you can
enumerate with that complexity and now
let's see actually updates in this case
so if we update a0 let's say we have an
update a 0 B 0 in our case here this is
heavy now of course we get rid of a0
which just keep b0 and then we look up
in s
uh and that we propagate the update so
that would be constant time
um so updates to to the heavy part of R
is constant now in s we look up uh uh
you know we have this update and then we
just look up on the other side which is
again having just the B's and then we
look up in it it's constant time and we
propagate it so in both cases the update
time will be constant so if we put this
together for this query
what we see is that uh uh the
pre-processing time is the linear in the
light case is this in the heavy case and
overall is linear
the animation delay would be constant in
the light case but it's this the number
of B's right the heavy B's n21 minus
Epsilon the heavy case so overall is
this and the update time is this this
and that right
okay
so this means effectively that
um
we are for this one matching the lower
bound we've seen before
the lower bound tell told us that we
cannot go below
this guy in update and this guy in a
uh input processing for the case where
Epsilon B 0.5
right so for 0.5 we get square root of n
update time and square root of n delay
so the question is are there more
queries with the same weak Pareto
optimality as our previous example yes
query of these
are these the triangle queries and
then
um
okay the triangle query had a scalar
answer
yeah so there we are the the immigration
was constant ah yeah
yeah and then you are big time for for
our algorithm for other time was uh was
good for them so yes the update time
remained the same for the admiration
differed because we have daytime and
space right yes it was also the time and
space to trade off because there there
was no trade-off with with the answer
time we did with the delay
so are there more questions queries with
the same weak parietal optimality and
the answer is yes we call this class
Delta one I will say later what why why
Delta one why the one
um
I'm not sure whether whether it is worth
me going and explaining this this class
but what is actually important to get
out of it is that there is a syntactic
characterization of such a class
and in this class actually has exactly
the the update time and delay trade-off
that I showed for the for the special uh
instance of the class
okay so in particular uh for any such
query there is no algorithm that can do
this uh maintenance right with the
square root of well basically sub square
root of n update time N Sub square root
of n admiration delay unless the OMB
conjecture fails yeah
so we had this picture and then uh any
of these queries can be maintained in
fact with display processing time update
time and generation delay
so a reasonable and then we get this
line as I showed you also before the
reasonable question is why why do we
care so much about the trade-off
well of course there is a purely you
know theoretic interest in knowing
whether there is such a trade-off but
think about the fact that sometimes you
might want to only enumerate a part of
your answer
like you don't want to make the whole
answer then if you know you know what is
the proportion of the answer you want to
enumerate you know asymptotically you
can then tweak Epsilon such that you get
the overall best uh complexity and that
complexity may be less than the
complexity of just enumerating
everything and doing uh you know the
best update time possible right because
imagine the situation where you are only
interested in uh uh in a in in a few
tuples only in the answer
then then if you're interested in a few
tuples perhaps you want the update time
to be fast because even even if the
enumeration delay is high you'll only
pay the price a few times and not many
many times
yeah so in this sense it's actually
perhaps interesting also for from a
practical perspective
so what though what happens Beyond uh
Delta one
we can define a synthetically classes
Delta I
such that their update time is n2i times
Epsilon
yeah
so you see before it was just x0 now
this I well it was eyes was one and I
times have similar big time but the
delay remains one minus Epsilon so there
is still some trade-off between the two
yeah just the update time increases
and in particular if I zero the Delta 0
hierarchy means exactly the two
hierarchical queries you've seen before
yeah because for them indeed uh this
update time becomes uh n to zero it
becomes one of one and then you can
choose Epsilon freely and we can choose
Epsilon to be one
um
so beyond a Delta I hierarchical we have
the hierarchical queries that admit this
sort of trade-off the update time now
has a parameter here here instead of the
is called Delta which we Define it as a
dynamic width yeah and here for
pre-processing there is a parameter W
which is the we call it static wheel
which is in fact nothing but you know
FAQ with let me put it this way what is
the fractional hyperte width for for
arbitrary conjunctive queries not only
for Boolean conjunctive queries so how
you get to that imagine you you know for
those familiar with hyperte
decompositions you try to take a free
hyperte decomposition such that you know
the three variables uh are are somewhere
placed uh uh in in in in in in you know
uh connected backs right okay and so so
that restricts the the search space for
the hypothetic compositions you can take
and that that gives you actually uh
and the dynamic width is nothing but you
look at the the Delta queries you can
get the different updates you can do
right and then for each of these Delta
queries you look at what what is this
static with
then we take a maximum over those and
that will be the dynamic width
okay so this is where actually uh you
know that the query structure plays a
role because I got the question earlier
now this fractional hyperte width looks
at the query structure and decomposes
the query right uh in a way where uh you
can uh you can actually do more local
computation as local as you can instead
of doing everything globally
good so uh now an open question which
you know I we don't know how to address
but would be very delighted to get any
any insight here and you know it was
very inspirational to see this this
reduction from set to OV you know in the
previous day because that one actually
might might allow us to look for lower
bounds for hierarchical queries which
are not just the simple ones we actually
have done uh before queries where the
update time may be you know quadratic
let's say or maybe Beyond quadratic
so now the nice thing about this this
trade-off also it shows that we can get
you know uh so this is the the actual
line in this uh 3D space of update time
uh delay and pre-processing time this is
the line we can achieve with the with
the trade-off and you know in this Cube
which is basically uh marking the the
sublinger update time and sub-linear
delay and it turns out that all these
points here right can be achieved so
basically the algorithm can achieve
sublinear update time and sublinear
delay which is also shown here uh uh you
know so uh so this is something that
that wasn't known before whether we can
achieve both of them sublinger
good so beyond a hierarchical well we
try there is no nice Clause form
expression for the complexities yeah we
basically have to compute some linear
program and uh you know whatever we get
out of it would represent our our
complexities and uh I realize also that
for Alpha basically queries Traders seem
not possible so far
and we did four steps for Alpha
basically queries in in this CSL paper
so if we put this in an IVM landscape
right uh we realize the following so we
have you know we look at pre-processing
time update time and iteration delay for
conjunctive queries we know that you
know we take pre-processing time which
depends on the fractional hyper 2 width
then uh you know update time depends on
this Dynamic width I showed you and then
we have constant delay effectively here
we construct a factorized representation
which takes this time and then we can
maintain it uh efficiently and then from
it we can enumerate with constant delay
uh then the the triangle join I showed
you before that can achieve this now in
Alpha AC click we have several results
known for frequent x uh stength and
sumeren and Martin
Ugarte and others they show the
effectively that you can get a linear
pre-processing a linear update time and
constant delay
now we we show this thing for
hierarchical which I already mentioned
before and at the intersection of the
two we have two classes we have the two
hierarchical queries of Nicole
and we have also the Delta one
hierarchical
so effectively all hierarchical queries
which are in this Delta one they are
also free Conex
and they have basically the static with
the fractional hypertrude with one or
two and the dynamic width is one
whereas the the Q hierarchical they have
the static with one and the dynamic with
zero that allows for this constant to
update time in delay
so this algorithm also recovers when we
restricted to hierarchical queries can
recover existing works so this is the
one for hierarchical we can achieve the
conjunctive we can achieve the frequent
X Delta 1 and Delta 0 as a special cases
so it's an algorithm that somehow you
know achieves what has been known before
when restricted to to hierarchical
queries we just don't know yet how to go
you know elegantly Beyond hierarchical
queries this is our problem
good so yes
foreign
to be ranked According to some rank
function there has been Works done on
that I mean I know parties did work here
Wolfgang did work on this uh
um so so the thing is think about this
so if you want particular rank
enumeration this actually imposes some
restriction on the hypertia compositions
you can consider
and that is likely to to to increase the
the static width and automatically also
the dynamic width but but it can be
incorporated immediately like that it's
just a matter of choosing the right
decomposition which allows you for that
ranked enumeration
yes
outside in the in the wild
um
so the question is uh in the wild is it
likely that Q hierarchical queries
appear often I mean I'm a city boy and I
don't really go in the wild that much
last time I went in the wild I broke my
leg
so uh you know
um I cannot tell you because I don't
know why
but all I can say I mean to me while it
is already relational AI right so I
looked at making my life for the wild in
my life
but and they said they have you know
statistics they collected and Society
build the tool that collected statistics
on on their workloads how many queries
are actually uh too hierarchical and you
know they look like you know some
percentage like 20 30 percent if I'm
almost I can uh you know uh but under
under functional dependencies
but for that they also use a trick which
is actually very very common it turns
out they take aquarium and whenever you
know the domain of a variable is small
they specialize the query into many
queries
right
and these queries you get you know these
residuals if you like right they are
more likely to be hierarchical whereas
the original ones perhaps they were not
so basically the concepts
yeah exactly yeah
because there are a few constants you
can plug this another thing is like you
know uh uh you know 14 years ago I did
the following um
um exercise I do ppch which is a
stand-up Benchmark for data basis I
looked at all the queries and I looked
at the The Joint part right so I took
away the the bells and whistles that are
actually relevant but you know just I
wanted to understand whether the number
line join is hierarchical and it turned
out that under functional dependencies
because in tpch you have a lot of t480
constraints right the functional
dependence is like 20 out of 26 queries
for hierarchical
right yeah so that was a very large
number
right which was used at that time for
probabilistic databases because it meant
that we can compute exactly you know
efficiently probabilities in probability
data you know of course taking aside as
I said a lot of the Aggregates and so on
right
good uh I have a couple more minutes
which is fantastic because I want just
to give you a very high level
perspective on how to maintain something
more complicated over over the
relational databases not only queries in
particular imagine that that you know a
common scenario would be you want to
train models over relational data yeah a
typical scenario is you just do the join
you collect the sources you put them
together in a big data Matrix and then
you learn over it
um and then what happens if you want to
maintain the the model well you have to
maintain the result and then you export
it again and then you retrain but in
fact it can be done better in the sense
that we can actually uh you know look
what what exactly makes up the the model
training and realize there are a lot of
essentially queries there right queries
with Aggregates like you know the you
know Computing The covariance Matrix
represents a uh you know basically can
be represented by some products over the
join of the of the table
right of course it can be a bit more
involved in case you have categorical
features but for the time being stay
with me that that you know we can
actually uh have continuous features we
we also have a way to do it for uh for
categorical ones so I'll show you three
very briefly three examples polynomial
regression yeah so we want to basically
we have this input which uh think of the
input X and Y the output both given by
database joins so you construct them
using some database joins and these are
the parameters in between and what you
want to find is the best parameters that
uh you know would fit this equation
and uh and the way you can solve it is
for instance you can do a gradient
descent in which case uh you just uh you
know look at the the gradient
computation step right and then in this
one you realize you have D6 transpose X
which is nothing but the covariance
Matrix which may not be centered in
general here yeah so we want to see you
know because this depends on data this x
transpose x and x transpose y depends on
data can we do anything there can we
maintain that computation over the
joints and the second uh scenario we
looked at was uh whether we can maintain
cholu trees on the changes to the to the
database and surely trees you know to
compute them I mean already D mentioned
that you know how we can do this I will
not go much into detail except that we
have to look at the pairwise mutual
information
right but pairwise Mutual information
can be derived from the covariance
Matrix in fact yeah so effectively we
want to maintain the covariance Matrix
this covariance Matrix
in SQL and I apologize for this in SQL
but uh you know it allows me to put a
lot of Aggregates together in the head
yeah uh we can have uh uh The covariance
Matrix is pressed like this so these are
this this is the underlying join and on
top we have uh you know the count the
sum over every single uh variable
and then uh we also have the account uh
the sum over the product of the
variables we've been taken pairwise
right so we have a n by n well n plus 1
by n plus one such U Aggregates can we
maintain them efficiently is the
question
so yes we can do that yeah we can look
at this as being you know we have the
count which is sum of one we have the
vector of the sum over each variable
this could be as I said a vector and
then we can have a matrix of sum of x i
x J's
so we can put this together in a ring
which we call covariance ring where the
elements are uh triples which are
integers vectors and matrices
and we have neutral elements for some in
product operations which are these ones
here
and then we can actually I will show you
an example of how you can do summation
and product in this ring
so if you imagine that we have two LM
two elements like this A and B yeah
summation is nothing but this you sum up
the counts yeah you sum up the vectors
and you sum up the matrices
then if you want to do multiplication
you multiply the counts
you multiply the count of this guy with
the with the vector of the other and the
count of the second with the vector of
the first and we put them together
yeah and then for the for the matrices
for the last part what you do is that
you first scale up the Matrix of the
first using the count of the second plus
the The Matrix of the of the of the
first using the the the count of the
second sorry and the count of the First
with the with the Matrix of the second
yeah and then what you do is also you
take the outer products of the vectors
in both ways the first Vector with the
second and the second with the first so
it is a commutative rig
so can this be helpful yes definitely I
can show you performance numbers I will
not show them here yeah but we have them
uh actually and they look really
impressive in particular because
whenever we did before multiplicity
computation right which was actually
propagated all the way down to relations
and done before joints now instead we do
this covariance computation pushed past
the joints yeah so for instance if we
join and we have only a few variables
few few features you know for that part
of the join we only work on on those
features so we compute a covariance
matrix for them on the other side the
compute covariance Matrix for other
features and then when you bring them
together while join we then create a
covariance matrix for the whole thing
and the fact that we can do this
together is actually also helpful
because you see we use the count
basically for computation with the
matrices and the vectors and we use the
vectors for the computation or in the
matrices so there is a lot of share
computation which actually can lead to
lots of orders of magnitude improvement
over a standard approach that just does
every cell in The covariance Matrix
independently
good and with that I'm done on time
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yes okay could you go to the slides with
the landscape that you have yeah
so everything you told us is under the
use of Maximum is that correct
so if you use set some money do
something to become easier or simpler to
you know so the problem with the
so the problem with the with the
credential methods is that okay so one
approach is to actually use use normal
duplicity so you know how many
derivations you get for coupling the
answer if you would use set thematics
all the time you might have to Red
arrive
whether a tuple you know the answer is
still there and that that is likely to
cost more time
than actually less
so if you force yourself not to use the
the count
yeah
yeah it is in fact an idea
there may be some other method that
doesn't involve the account it's not
obviously it's not obvious what it is I
wanted to give you an example one of
such methods you know so so Mahmoud had
an idea wonderful idea that perhaps
instead of hitting the count which maybe
actually we have to eagerly maintain all
the time even if there is a change in
the number of derivations right so the
Tuple itself doesn't change in the
output but the number of derivations
change you may think of uh keeping
something like a weakness
so you don't give the full lineage like
a water sorry provenance
provenance as as a peer mentioned but
imagine it gives someone uh you know you
pick randomly you know some weakness
from the province
right
yeah so if you do that perhaps you know
you can still get a you know not
asymptotically but in practice better
than actually maintaining an account
so I in other words you know to
summarize I do not know of a method that
will do more efficiently for sets
so I I had a question here so is the
pre-call next case when did their update
time is off and I think it's equivalent
to just a computer interpretation
yes
no no benefit here from incremental I
mean asymptotically yes but practically
you know it's a bit different of course
because you get the data and compute
just the cyclic Delta query which is one
of the relations is smaller
right but that's important convenience
is the same as uh
the cases no better than any computers
yes yes so the hierarchical class okay
can be speaking to a disjoint Union of
of Delta ice right okay right for some I
yeah they are a partition that will
adjust more subsets of hierarchical
questions
yes yes so the idea is uh can we do can
we be more efficient if we if we never
insert purpose which are not in the
database we just played with that with
the with let's say a payload with the
arena
um
that that that setting is much closer to
linear algebra uh because in an algebra
you get basically the Matrix you know
for sure the domain of every variable
you know it literally is from one to n
right and what you do is just change the
payload there and it turns out yes in
that case uh so let me try to go
um to one of the things I wanted to show
you here
in that case I was I was able to show
but I don't have it anywhere that this
line actually can collapse so you can
get you can get a point here you can get
the point there
right so it can be done better
yeah
but this uses the fact that you know if
you look at RNs
right in terms of matrices R being a
matrix that is of quadratic size whereas
s is of linear size in N is small n
right so you can take advantage of the
difference in the in the sizes
right to get a better trade-off
so it is possible
I would like to investigate this of
course for for more classes of queries
but as I said it seems to be more
particular to
for me at least the you know Matrix
calculus because this is where I know
the the domains are fixed right they
just iterate from one to n
yes
so do you keep additional information
like these to keep track of which tables
are presented when you do this batch
so uh so this is a question regarding
flores's uh question uh before so what
happened with the with the with the
negative payloads it turns out uh uh you
know has the perfect answer
so I would just refer to him he just
mentioned to me that he discussed with
Flores about that and it's still
possible to do it uh and uh yeah we can
we can just talk with him afterwards so
I don't know
they take the blow different information
is different from the one we discussed
oh okay okay
yes
so like the ring as possible your plus
operation is not like
so uh you mean when I try to show these
covariance ring for instance it's right
where we can focus in general whenever
you have a ring you should be able to
use this technique right it's just that
uh uh you know you know if you are if
you are dealing with the semi ring then
then you can only do these sorts you
cannot do this
yeah so that's that's that's a short
answer so yeah you can put you know at
the end of my paper I had the uh
basically a line from a song by Beyonce
if you like it you should put a ring on
it
you don't understand it must be a full
ring
last question from
foreign
so you're only allowed to change
Elementary from zero to non-zero ones or
something or a small double I mean every
week
okay
yeah
so so
there is one more aspect nevertheless if
if your update is actually a low rank
decomposition
you can actually still do better so that
is your your update to The Matrix comes
as a sum with all the products or
vectors and in that case you can still
do better than actually having a whole
Matrix subject so look into that uh and
uh it's also part of the of the PHD
thesis of miloshi Rico which one of the
core threats
okay I think it's a good time to stop
listening
foreign
[Applause]